well let's go live now to Ahmed Idris
who is in Mali's capital Bamako Flores
hi there are camed so what then was the
outcome of that emergency meeting of the
g5 Suhail members that happened in
Nazaire well basically the leaders
realized that acting alone in tackling
the violence in their region will not
help and will not work so they've
resolved to forge closer collaboration
between civil and military institutions
in their regions as well as help
communities especially on the front
lines then they also resolve to lobby
hard for international allies to come
but they also want any cooperation
between their soldiers and international
forces to be that of mutual respect and
understanding remember there are more
than 15,000 international forces in the
region but largely these attacks are
being carried out the attacks being
carried out by armed groups in the Sahel
were actually targeted mainly at
military positions military positions in
Burkina Faso in Mali and Niger in
particular and these armies for most of
the times have been acting alone
defending their territories and these
are ill-equipped and poorly funded
militaries in the region of the Sahel
they don't have enough resources and the
territory they cover is actually so wide
that they don't have enough resources to
deal with these problems Achmed the UN
Security Council's holding a meeting
about security in West Africa right now
I wonder how do people there feel about
whether the UN can actually do anything
about the violence across as you say
such a vast region well the feeling here
across the streets of the Sahel is that
of expectations is also a better
frustration like we said there are more
than 15,000 international troops in the
Sahel trying to keep the peace but
despite their presence here we see a lot
of attacks a rising number of deaths on
the military side large-scale
displacement of civilians and
wasn't in conditions humanitarian
conditions I spoke to the resident
representative of the World Food Program
here in Mal in Mali and she was talking
about how the last few years people were
unable to go to the farm and because of
that their food security situation is
becoming more and more precarious so
people here are so much they've taken so
much that they feel they cannot take
anymore however they feel that the
international forces here in the region
should do more than they have they are
already doing to to curb the the number
of attacks being carried out not only on
military targets but also on civilians
in the region so they are looking at the
meeting of the United Nations in New
York with expectations that the United
Nations will do more international
troops that deployed here will also do
more to curb the rise in cases of
attacks in the region ahmed idris there
with live with the latest from Bamako
ahmed thank you